environment ministers meeting in
brussels agreed to reopen discussions to
consider the possibility for member
states to restrict or even prohibit the
cultivation in all or part of their
territory of genetically modified
organisms that have already been
authorized at eu level
while they are widely grown in the
americas and asia genetically modified
crops are generally unpopular in europe
where public opposition is strong and
there are concerns about their impact on
biodiversity the greek presidency aims
to reach a political agreement on this
issue before the end of 2014.
you must assume i think that if
we all work together
we will get a political agreement by the
end of this presidency so that at long
last member states do have the freedom
to ban gmos if they so wish within their
territory
ministers also discussed the new
framework for climate and energy policy
for 2013 and stressed the need to
prepare for the international
negotiations for a global agreement on
climate change
on the annual growth survey 2014
ministers agreed on the need to improve
the uptake of green economy priorities
into the national reform programs of
member states and in the overall
semester cycle